and on Capitol Hill we are witnessing
the end of an era house Speaker Nancy
Pelosi the first and only woman to hold
the job and now she will not seek a
leadership position in the next Congress
though she says she will continue to
represent her District Nicole killing is
on Capitol Hill with more on the story
Nicole good morning to you the speaker
is winning rare praise from both sides
of the aisle and I understand there were
a lot of Tears in the room yesterday
yeah a lot of tears and a lot of hugs
Gail and you know listen it's no secret
that speaker Pelosi and Senate minority
leader Mitch McConnell didn't always see
eye to eye but in his statement last
night he called her impact consequential
and said her path-breaking career is one
that will long endure
I will not seek re-election to
Democratic Leadership in the next
congress with that announcement Thursday
house Speaker Nancy Pelosi ended
speculation about her political future
for me the hours come for a new
generation to lead the Democratic caucus
that I so deeply respect and reflected
on her Legacy as the first and only
female speaker never would I have
thought that someday I would go from
Homemaker to house speaker in fact I
never
thanking her husband Paul who was
recently attacked the 82-year-old mother
of five was applauded by lawmakers on
the left and some on the right embraced
by colleagues in The Well of the house
like congresswoman Barbara Lee who
serves with Pelosi in the California
delegation he's been such a great leader
who has led us through many many as I
said transformational policies the
Affordable Care Act the infrastructure
building inflation reduction first
elected in 1987 Pelosi earned the
speaker's gavel in 2007. Nancy Pelosi I
extend to you this gavel
and again in 2019 power of the speaker
is awesome
awesome
she worked with at least four presidents
some she got along with others she did
not her exit comes as Majority Leader
steny Hoyer also announced plans to step
down from leadership clearing the path
for a potential new crop of leaders
including Democratic caucus chair Hakeem
Jeffries who is expected to announce his
bid for minority leader today I think we
all hope in whatever capacity we find
ourselves in to
benefit from the wisdom guidance and
advice of speaker Nancy delisandre
Pelosi
now if elected Jeffries would become the
first African-American to lead a party
in Congress and he would primarily be
tasked with taking on GOP leader Kevin
McCarthy who was recently nominated as
Speaker after Republicans were projected
to flip the house McCarthy notably was
not present during Pelosi's speech
telling reporters he was in meetings
David
um Nicole thank you